>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Hello, everyone.
My name is Betsy Peterson.
I'm the Director of the American
Folklife Center here at the Library
of Congress, and on
behalf of the staff,
I want to welcome you all today.
It's a gorgeous day here,
and I'm really pleased
that you all are here
to share it with us.
This is a special program, part
of our Homegrown Concert Series,
part of our Lecture Series, and
it's an opportunity for us to have,
for us to engage in a
conversation with individuals
who have been awarded the
National Heritage Fellowship,
which is the highest honor
given to traditional artists
in the United States by the
National Endowment for the Arts,
and we're thrilled to have
actually not just two;
we have three here today with
us, and that's very exciting.
All the way from California,
we Roy and PJ Hirabayashi,
the leaders of San Jose Taiko,
and we have Daniel Sheehy,
the Ethno Music College's Director
Emeritus of Smithsonian Folkways,
and actually, a National
Endowment Heritage Fellow
for Cultural Advocacy.
So, he's going to be doing some of
this cultural advocacy work today,
interviewing our artists here.
Just as a little bit of background
the Homegrown Series is an
opportunity for the American
Folklife Center to work
with cultural specialists
folklorists at the Music colleges,
artists around the country
to identify the very best
of traditional arts, music,
dance, narrative, arts,
and work with individuals
to bring artists here
to share their traditions with
all of you and to consent,
agree to be recorded
for our archives.
And this session today
is no different.
It will be recorded, and this
conversation will be in our archives
so that future generations
can access it,
and people around the world will
be able to view and listen to it.
So, with that little caveat, let me
ask you to turn off your cell phone,
if you have such a
thing and have it on,
or else you will memorialized
in our archive as well.
I also want to thank,
actually, while I'm on the topic
of acknowledgements and
talking about partners
and individuals we work with, I
also want to thank Mark Rooney today
of Washington, DC,
who was very gracious,
for learning his drums today
because I believe the
San Jose Taiko Drums are
over on the mall right now
and need to stay there.
So, but at any rate, so our
program today, acknowledged as one
of the Premiere Music
Ensembles in the United States,
San Jose Taiko was founded in 1973
by young Asian Americans searching
to convey their experiences as
third generation Japanese Americans
and inspired by traditional
Japanese drumming.
Company performers express
the beauty and harmony
of the human spirit through
the voice of the Taiko drum,
and as they strive to create new
dimensions in music, movement,
and tradition, San Jose Taiko's
performances feature visual elements
in choreography requiring
physical strength,
endurance, focus, and energy.
And the members of the group
participate in composing,
choreographing, designing,
and fabricating costumes
and hand crafting the drums.
This collective effort
produces a performance
that highlights group
unity and purpose.
In 1987, San Jose Taiko became one
of the first American
Taiko ensembles
to be invited to perform in Japan.
They have performed in
a wide range of venues,
from small community
centers throughout California
and schools, to Carnegie Hall.
In addition to offering
extensive educational
and community outreach programs,
San Jose Taiko is currently working
on establishing a Taiko
Conservatory, the first of its kind
in the United States,
which is exciting.
I hope we'll hear more about that.
Roy and PJ are credited for
developing a holistic art form
that embraces artistic excellence,
while also encouraging
San Jose Taiko members
to become leaders and
community builders.
So, please, let's welcome
Roy and PJ Hirabayashi,
National Heritage Fellows,
and Dan Sheehy.
[ Audience Applause ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: Thank you, Betsy.
You said everything
I was going to say,
so I don't have anything
left to say.
Thank you all for coming here today.
We can't have this
presentation without you all here,
so you're very much a part of this.
And I have to say, just
to start off myself,
that I'm so incredibly humbled to
be here on this little platform
with two of the most articulate
activist traditional artists
that this country, or maybe
beyond, has ever produced.
And so, it's I just feel
so moved and humbled
to be here with you also.
Thank you for taking the time to
come up to the Library of Congress.
>> Roy Hirabayashi: Thank you.
[Inaudible]
>> PJ Hirabayashi:
He's totally honored.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Okay.
So, why don't we start
with a why question.
Why Taiko?
And you know, this goes
back to, as Betsy mentioned
in her opening remarks there,
there were things happening
in the late 1960's and
early 1970's in California,
particularly the Bay Area
perhaps, in particular.
Can you set the scene and
give us a sense of why?
Why are we here today?
Why we have these drums?
>> Roy Hirabayashi: Sure.
Well, yes, in the late
1960's, I think probably some
of you can remember at
that time was really a lot
of happenings happening
in our country.
The Social Justice
Movement was really,
the Civil Rights Movement
was really active;
the Anti-War Movement was going
on, and so at that time it was also
for a lot of people of color,
it was a search of identity,
asking the question of
what is my heritage,
what is my ethnic background,
where do my family,
where does my family come from,
and how do we fit here in America.
I'm Sansei, third generation; so,
my grandparents emigrated here
from Japan, from Hiroshima
[phonetic] area.
My parents were born here
in the United States,
but they were actually sent back to
Japan to be raised from elementary
to high school, and then came back
to the US just before
World War II broke out.
So, they were primary Japanese
speaking when they returned
to the US, so they're
considered what's called,
they're Nisei second generation, but
they're considered Kepay [phonetic],
raised in Japan but
American citizens.
Sansei, I was born right after
World War II in the early 1950's,
and so at that time for us,
for me, it was really kind
of the search of who I was.
I was a Japanese American,
and within that context
of what was going on
again in the late 1960s.
That was the beginning of
Ethnic Studies on campuses.
Again, the Anti-War Movement was
going on, the war in Southeast Asia;
so, for a lot of us, it was just
trying to search how that identity
or search for what we were
as Japanese Americans was
really kind of what's going on.
And so, I've always loved music,
playing music in different ways,
and so when I discovered the
Taiko, the Japanese drum,
I quickly discovered or found that
this was a voice that was missing
in my life because growing up
there was no musical voice for me
that really connected to my
heritage as a Japanese American..
PJ can answer that.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Can I just ask
when was that very first moment
that you heard or saw a Taiko drum?
>> Roy Hirabayashi: Well, actually,
growing up, I heard Taiko playing
in our festivals in our,
in the Japanese community,
but for me to really connect to it,
it was in actually the early 1970's
when I first heard a San
Francisco Taiko group,
and there's another group
in Los Angeles called the
Keyano [phonetic] Taiko.
We started San Jose Taiko
in 1973, so it was around
and that really it's connecting
to the ideas around 1972, 1973 on.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Great.
Thanks. PJ?
>> PJ Hirabayashi: Ditto.
[Laugh] Just to kind of cap on our
similarities, my grandparents are
from Japan, and my parents were born
in California, and I grew up in,
well, I was born in 1950, so right
after World War II, I
went to public school.
That was 1955-ish, and I was
the only Asian face at school,
and I was quickly reminded
that I was already different.
And there was something about going
to school and already being cast
out as being different and not
included and the separation
of like why am I not being included.
So, there was already this very
seething feeling of inferiority,
less than, no self-esteem, and
that's how I actually felt,
you know, not being included
for a long period of time.
And so, just kind of quickly
forward, to have heard Taiko
in the early 1970's, all of
a sudden became like "Wow!"
I saw this energy, you know, and
they were, there were men and women.
They were all dressed
up in happi coat,
and in San Francisco [inaudible].
By the way, Sage Tanaka is
also a Heritage Fellow too.
And to be able to see this unabashed
energy coming from the stage,
this expression, and immediately
it's like I want to do that;
almost like, I can do that.
How can I do that?
And so it was like that exploration
of, okay, I want to find Taiko,
how I could become like this.
I always use the word "ballistic,"
you know, being a woman too,
it's like you're always, and Asian
woman too, so ballistic was like,
okay, let go, you know, this
is self-expression at its best,
and I don't have to talk.
This is the way I'm going
to communicate with you.
This is how loud I'm going to become
that I could not show you as I
as growing up as a little girl.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Were women very
much a part of the Taiko scene
that you were exposed to back then?
>> PJ Hirabayashi: In the very
beginning, it was very prominent.
I mean, I would say that,
well, for San Jose Taiko,
as we started in 1973, we
were like about 85% women.
>> Roy Hirabayashi: Women.
>> PJ Hirabayashi: Yeah.
I think we were all
searching for something,
whether we were conscious
of it or no.
You know, it's like that
freedom of expression,
and people coming together and doing
something and exploring together;
not, you know, there is
kind of root culture,
but how does it affect us
living here in America,
how does it translate,
how is it different?
>> Daniel Sheehy: Right.
Could you, this might be, is
this the time to give us a sense
of that wild moment, what you
heard that sort of grabbed you
and pulled you into this, right now?
This is part of our
plan, just so you know.
[ Laughter ]
>> PJ Hirabayashi: Orchestrated.
>> Roy Hirabayashi: Well,
this is a great opportunity
for us just to demonstrate a piece.
This piece is called Celebration.
It's a duet piece that
PJ and I wrote.
I can't even remember
when it was we wrote this,
but it's a number of years back.
But it'll feature so many
small drums that we have here.
The Taiko comes in many
different sizes; unfortunately,
we could not bring some of
the large ones here today,
but we have a nice sample
from Mark Rooney to show you.
Again, Celebration.
[ Drums Performance ]
[ Audience Applause ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: My turn.
[Laugh]
[ Audience Laughter ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: We were
pleased that [inaudible]
and I to have a little class
before you all came here today,
so I think we'll refrain, right.
We'll just leave it to PJ.
So, we've moving from the why
a little bit into the what.
So, you heard a little bit of
the what, and you're looking
at some of the what here.
Can you tell us what,
well, maybe what is Taiko?
Maybe we just start there
and kind of go, move out.
>> Roy Hirabayashi:
Well, first of all,
Taiko is the Japanese word
for the Japanese drum.
So, it refers to all the different
size drums you actually will see
in Japan or here in
the United States now,
and actually you could see just
from our small collection here
that we're using there's a variety
of different styles
that the drum comes in.
And as I mentioned before,
they actually be much larger.
In Japan, or even here in the US,
you'll see drums sort of up to four
or five feet in diameter,
weighing 3, 4,
500 pounds to this much smaller drum
that can actually be
held in one hand.
And so, what we have in collection
in general is the barrel
style Taiko,
which they call the Narvado
[phonetic] drum, See,
it's tacked on with tacks in
order to put the cowhide on there,
and the smaller drums, the real
small drum, we call the Shime Taiko.
It's double-headed with rope,
and you could adjust the tension
and the pitch with the rope,
and then the little bit longer
barrel drum in the middle,
we call kettle drum, which
is also barrel style,
made out of flat woods.
And those drums also are tied by
rope with the different heads.
And those, those kettles, also
come in many different sizes,
much smaller ones that you
carry around to larger ones
that would sit on a stand.
But in Japan, again, or here in
the United States, we use a variety
of different drums in order to
create the different pitches,
styles, uses within
movement or dance also,
and in order to really create the
music that we want to be doing.
>> PJ Hirabayashi: So, maybe what
we can explain is what you're seeing
today as kind of contemporary.
So, what we've been able to infuse
in our style is some understanding
and respect for the roots of
where Taiko come from, from Japan.
And in Japan, Taiko
was really never used
for art sake; it was for life sake.
It's to accompany the prayers and
chanting for good harvest and rain,
and also to chase away
the insects from crops,
and in time of bountiful
harvest there was celebration;
so, for a good harvest.
Even warriors would use the sound
of Taiko to frighten their enemy.
The villagers would use Taiko to
have people congregate in the center
of the village when there
was a time to come together.
But Kumi-daiko, K-u-m-i, in
Japanese it means "ensemble."
Ensemble playing really
did not become popular
until after World War II,
and I think this is all
from the same reason like why we
play joyfully for a celebration.
This is after World War II, and in
Japan there were some Taiko players
that they felt that, wow, we need
to kind of reinvigorate to become,
you know, enliven, uplift ourselves
for after a harsh World War,
and that's how Kumi-daiko started
to become popular in Japan.
So, it's, we're not talking
about ancient Kumi-daiko playing.
So, that's what really
infused our interest.
Like how do we use this as a
tool of bringing people together,
building community,
and like expression?
There was no way.
Remember, when we started a group
in the 1970's we didn't have any
cell phones or computers, so LPs,
you know, we would buy these
LPs from Japan and play it;
and yet there was something
about it that we felt that, wow,
let's recognize these rich
traditions from Japan,
but let's just don't copy.
You know, we just don't want to
copy or appropriate those songs.
Let's create music that comes
from us, you know, and let's also,
we didn't, we couldn't afford
drums -- quickly going back,
we didn't afford drums from Japan
because one small drum would cost
like $3000 to $5000 just
for a group to have.
So, one of our predecessor groups,
Sansei Taiko down in Los
Angeles, was very innovative.
They took a wine barrel that they
bought in Los Angeles and wanted
to make Taiko become accessible like
more through the Buddhist Temple
and activities to draw in young
people because there was kind
of like young people were losing
interest in Buddhist religion.
So, Sansei Taiko,
>> Roy Hirabayashi: Kinnaro.
>> PJ Hirabayashi:
Kinnaro Taiko, excuse me,
devised these wine barrel Taiko,
which actually is the predecessor
of American Taiko, and
that's what you see here.
It's actually a combination.
I think there's two drums, the
small pitch drums that are roped
from Japan, and the other three
drums are actually made here
in the States.
>> Daniel Sheehy: So, if you
had your full group here,
here we have one, two, three,
four, five drums, two players,
how many drums and how many
people would we have here
for a typical San Jose Taiko?
>> Roy Hirabayashi: For San
Jose Taiko, I think we have
about 22 performing members.
There's occasions at home where
we'll play with all members
and actually fill up an
entire room out on the stage,
and so, and a variety of drums.
So, when we tour, actually,
we're touring with a good almost 20
different drums of different sizes
in order to do one
performance concert.
There's a base, I guess, style
or ensemble drum, which is about,
I guess, about 10 pieces
minimum that we would use,
but they're much larger
than what we have here.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Mm-hmm.
Okay. Yeah, I was wondering
about that
because I thought I could hear
the [inaudible] Stradivarius
Strings resonating.
[Laughing] Okay.
I just wondered if we
have like 10 more drums,
what would happen to
the glass over there.
So, help us out here, so when
we're listening to you all perform,
or San Jose Taiko perform, what
should we pay attention to?
I mean, obviously, there's movement.
There's a visual aspect there.
There's sound, there's
quite a bit going on.
Give us something to grab onto here.
>> PJ Hirabayashi: Well, I
would say, as a viewer audience,
just listen with open
mind and open heart.
Don't categorize us as saying,
that's not authentic from Japan.
And I think also what we really want
to have people experience is kind
of finding your own story, how
in our explanation of the songs
that are created by individuals
within San Jose Taiko Company,
there's a backstory to every song.
So, you make it your, we won't
tell you exactly what to think.
So, we want you to
kind of like imagine.
But I really love at the end
of a performance at a concert
in a theatre, and we go to the
lobby and thank the audience
for coming out, we will
often hear people say,
"Oh, wow, you made me cry."
Or, "Wow! I'm just
feeling so great."
And you go, "Thank
you, and I'm sorry."
No, but there's something about
that experience that you touch them.
You know, if there was that tear
that came up, there was something
that they were able to experience.
So, it's kind of like, yeah,
we leave it out for the
expression to speak for itself.
>> Roy Hirabayashi: We're
like that people got to decide
for themselves what they want to
take from it without a certain,
being guided in a certain
direction, right.
>> PJ Hirabayashi: I do say
that like in the philosophy
of San Jose Taiko that
there is purpose
and intention behind
everything that we do,
and even though we don't tell you,
it's a little way through our,
you know, selves that we're
communicating, you know, this,
the principles of playing
together as an ensemble of oneness,
of open heart, open mind.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Bessie Peterson
mentioned that the opening remarks
that I was trained as
an Ethnomusicologist,
and one of the things that I
gathered from all that training was
that music has absolutely
no meaning whatsoever.
I mean, it has absolutely
no meaning whatsoever except
for the meaning that people give it.
And I'm curious, what,
could you talk a little bit
about the two sides
of that conversation?
Like what meaning, examples of
meaning that you've given the music,
either musically or in terms of that
story behind it, as you were saying.
And then, what meaning have you seen
people take from it or add to it,
you know, like people
sitting here right here today?
Can you give us a sense
of those two sides
of that conversation a little
bit from your experience?
>> Roy Hirabayashi: Sure.
I'll start with that.
Well, when we started San Jose
Taiko, we're the third group
to begin here in North America,
and probably at that time outside
of Japan, as far as this
particular ensemble form.
So, we were, as PJ mentioned, trying
to draw from experience or sounds
that we felt were coming from Japan
but more importantly
what was we felt,
we grew up as as Japanese Americans,
and so the music we
were writing early
on really incorporated
a lot of that influence.
And so when you hear our music,
you may kind of sense of a jazz
or an Afro-Cuban thing going on,
or polyrhythmic stuff happening,
and so you might get that kind
of sense of a rhythm going
on that you'll be hearing
when we're playing.
And so, I'm hoping as a
musician, or as a Taiko player,
that people when they are listening
to us as musicians are playing music
that really kind of
touches different aspects
of what you may really enjoy as a
listener or just enjoy of music.
So, you might sense as the soloist
doing different things and that kind
of things happening and
also different textures
of what the different drums
may be doing at the same time.
And so, it's really trying
to combine a lot of that,
and then on top of
that is the movement.
So, for those who enjoy dance
and movement, there's that piece
of what Taiko is all about too.
So, we're trying to combine
what we many times refer
to as dancing with the drums.
So, the audience could really
kind of enjoy that kind
of variety of what's happening.
So, we're hoping that as an audience
member you're not just focusing
on one person, but you're
looking at everybody
and really have a hard time
watching [inaudible] ensemble
because each person is
doing something different.
And rather than watching, say,
an orchestra or a string ensemble
where it's a little
bit more stationery.
And so, with that, it's really
just trying to create that,
the vibrancy of playing the
drum, having the opportunity
to just enjoy what we're playing,
and hopefully passing that on
to you too so you can enjoy that
experience too at the same time.
>> PJ Hirabayashi: It's
so multi-disciplinary,
as Roy is saying, there's the
physical aspect, musical aspect.
There's kind of like the
theatrical aspect as well.
So, as an audience, I imagine
somebody in a different discipline,
ethnic, you know, art, like wow,
I wonder what that sounds
like if we got together.
Like I'm feeling that there's
also this inciting excitement
of exploration.
Even as an artist, you
don't have to be musical.
Maybe it's like I want to
just experience what it's
like to hit that drum, you know.
And yeah, that's the invitation.
>> Daniel Sheehy: What about
stepping back, let's say, you know,
a football field, or
whatever, conceptually?
Festivals, I've gone
to, for example,
looking for a representation
of who is in a community,
or who's in a broader
community, or whatever.
And it seems like over the years
that Taiko has been selected as one
of those potent expressions
that it's more than music
in a general kind of way.
Do you have a take on that yourself,
or what would you see there?
You know what I'm trying
to, attempting to say here?
>> Roy Hirabayashi: Yes.
And we're excited about the fact
that, you know, we're, I mean,
again, we are trying to be
serious about our musical form
and what we compose, but as
a form in a musical entity
that we're really trying
to build a community,
so we realize that the drum
is a calling instrument
for the community itself.
And so, like you're
mentioning, I mean,
we play for City Hall officials,
football games and festivals
and school assemblies and, I mean,
weddings and even, unfortunately,
funerals, we've been
asked to play at.
But it's, basically, it's us being
asked to use the drum through,
as a voice to call people together
and to share that experience.
And so, that's one really important
thing that we feel about what Taiko
for us and what sounds
like Taiko's been trying
to do is use the instrument
in our music as a way
to help gather people together
and bring people together
to enjoy what's happening
as a community itself.
>> PJ Hirabayashi: I
have to add with that
that the first three Taiko
groups, of which we are the third,
actually [inaudible] were
started from Japan towns.
Three Japantowns who made
it in the United States
that are physical entities still
and recognized as Japantowns,
Los Angeles and San
Francisco and San Jose.
So, in that way, we see
like how important it became
as a pioneer voice for these
communities that, you know,
it's like, oh, I'd like to learn
more, you know, and it's like also,
hey, there's this celebration,
you know,
this is happening in Japantown.
Come on out.
And so there's also
this awareness building
of what the community
is and the larger city.
And then, also, we always
used to be asked, well,
do you have to be Japanese
to play the Taiko?
And I think, you know, that,
at the very beginning it
was like, no, you don't.
But please understand that we
are kind of exploring ourselves,
and it is a voice for the
Japanese American experience.
So, if you can be patient
and understand that's what
we're exploring, then yeah,
come join San Jose Taiko and to
be respectful of the tradition
and the history of like what
this community has gone through.
>> Daniel Sheehy: San Jose
Taiko is number three.
What are the differences say
between, say, what Sage Tanaka did
and the San Francisco Bay Area
in Keynata and Los Angeles
and what you are all doing?
And even looking today, hoping to
get a little sense of you today
and how things have evolved over
the years, but how are things?
Is everybody the same,
with the same philosophy,
or are there differences between?
>> Roy Hirabayashi: No, there are
differences in basic philosophy.
Sage Tanaka, [inaudible]
Taiko [inaudible] Joe,
really, he was trained in Japan.
He's an immigrant from Japan.
So, he really had brought
the Japanese traditional,
folk traditional of styles, festival
drumming to America, basically.
And so, his style and
form really kind of lies
in that direction of playing.
Keynata Taiko was based out
of the Senshin Buddhist Temple
with the Buddhist Church
in Los Angeles, Central LA,
and so Revo Muskodani [phonetic] and
those folks really kind of focused
on using the Taiko within
the Temple in a religion
and their activities around that.
Still a bit more contemporary
in a sense,
but philosophically it's
really around the ideas
of the religion and the Temple.
And so, when we started San
Jose Taiko, as we mentioned,
we came from a little bit
more of a Japanese American
and Asia American perspective,
and realizing that we didn't have
that kind of training
that we were just trying
to create our music
based upon what we felt.
So, it was really using a
lot of other different ideas
in order to create the music.
And so, we feel that San Jose Taiko,
we took more of a contemporary vein
of looking at how to
create our music and style.
And so, when you look at music,
the Taiko scene now you
could probably trace it back
to San Francisco Taiko,
more traditional,
to a little bit the Buddhist
path that the Kenata Taiko took
and then more the contemporary,
which style that we've taken.
In Japan, I feel that, and I'm
not saying this to brag or boast,
but I feel that what we've done here
in the United States has really kind
of influenced now what's
going on in Japan.
And although the Japanese Taiko
folks feel they're more traditional
in that sense, again, as PJ
mentioned, this art form for us,
this particular style only
started about the early 1950's.
And so, Taiko in the
United States era,
particularly has been running
parallel to what's going on in Japan
for about at least a good two-thirds
of that life span of this art form.
And so, with that, I think we've
greatly influenced now what's
happening in Japan as far as the
Taiko scene, the Kumi-daiko scene
where things that we were
being criticized for early on,
as far as using other
instrumentation, we would bring
in a cow bell and other
rhythm patterns,
and non-Japanese instruments.
Now, it's used all over,
especially in Japan.
And just the rhythmic
sense that we're doing,
that we were doing early on is also
being copied elsewhere all over.
And so, it's interesting
that I think Taiko
in America has influenced who
has gone now internationally
because now you see Taiko very
popular in Europe and Australia
and Asia and other countries,
and also South America.
So, it's really gone way beyond
what we experienced early on.
>> Daniel Sheehy: So, [inaudible].
>> PJ Hirabayashi: Yeah.
Actually, I wanted to say besides
what you hear and see, you know,
I think the three seminal groups
that started, we were very distinct
in our organization, and coming
from like community organizing
backgrounds or activism,
we wanted to be very clear that
we wanted some cooperation,
a cooperative collective
style of interaction
in how we operated as a group.
So, unlike a traditional Japanese
adieu [phonetic] or school,
where it's always popped down,
there is really no
lateral approach to that.
So, that's what we were doing.
We're just kind of making it
a lateral, even way of people,
inputting ideas, being creative,
how do we share responsibility.
So, I have to say that that kind
of still remains very distinct.
>> Roy Hirabayashi: Yeah,
yeah, that's big, essentially.
>> Roy Hirabayashi: Okay.
In terms of quantity,
okay, we got up to three.
Where are we now in
the United States,
and then beyond the United
States in terms of groups
or however you want to express it?
>> Roy Hirabayashi: Within,
for the longest time,
I was hearing about maybe
300 groups in North America,
but someone corrected me recently
saying that it's probably closer
to 450 in North America alone.
In South America now,
Taiko has been so popular,
it becomes real popular
too the last 15, 20 years.
So, there might be almost
equal numbers to that extent.
And as I mentioned, in Europe now,
it's really, it's just amazing,
and when countries were, even
not [phonetic] the Taiko,
this as an ensemble, it's
springing up all over Europe.
And so, it's really grown quite
a bit outside of Japan basically.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Does
that include, you know,
they're a sizeable Japanese
communities in Brazil and Peru,
for example, are those --
>> Roy Hirabayashi: Yes, important.
They really started a lot, right.
>> Daniel Sheehy: So, so far.
Yeah. And PJ, you mentioned a while
ago that a lot of people who are not
of Japanese descent are
interested in performing
and are performing Taiko music.
Can you tell us about
that a little bit?
Is that big, a little bit?
Is it, or it must be
special stories.
>> PJ Hirabayashi: I think there's
that flat line universal
concept, and that's heart.
So, you know, it doesn't
matter where or what you are;
it's just kind of an open door.
Well, that's what we try to do,
how to make Taiko accessible,
and it's very interesting.
I mean, there's no way of
knowing how Taiko is growing
or in what communities
it's developing.
Yes, there's a lot
more non-Asian faces
that are creating Taiko groups,
and then it's very interesting
to see a lot of non-Asian faces
that are really promoting
Taiko from Japan.
And it's interesting
to see the diversity
of like people being inspired
and influenced by the source
of where Taiko is coming from.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Mm-hmm.
How American is Taiko?
I mean, that's kind of a,
ever fully dumb question.
>> PJ Hirabayashi: Well, let me ask,
how many of you know what sushi is.
>> Daniel Sheehy: There you go.
>> PJ Hirabayashi: Okay, right.
Okay. So, that's what
Tomakasin [phonetic] say
from San Francisco
Taiko [inaudible].
You know, Taiko will
have hit the scene
if Taiko becomes as
ubiquitous as sushi.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Well, it's
pretty ubiquitous, as I said.
>> PJ Hirabayashi: I think it is.
Oh, and you don't, yeah, to
hear in commercials, you know,
very subliminally, on TV, you know;
it's like it's already
in compositions.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Look,
we have a couple
of more pieces before
we all adjourn here,
but is it okay to ask the questions.
People, who's in, somebody in
charge, can we do that, given this?
Yes. Oh, there's a microphone
for people to ask questions.
That's terrific.
So, let's let Viah [phonetic]
be our intermediary here.
How's that?
>> Thank you.
You're talking about trying to
find the uniqueness of Japanese
for the experience to the Taiko
drum and, as you mentioned,
there are many Japanese in
Brazil, and there's Samba there,
and if anybody that came
from another country
and start playing the drums, they
would play in their unique culture.
What makes Taiko unique
for Japanese?
And I guess, specifically, the
rudiments, the time signature,
the collaboration in unison.
You have to feel each other out
while you're playing together.
Maybe you can describe in regards
to the Taiko style for Japanese
in that experience
for being Japanese.
>> Roy Hirabayashi: Well,
it's definitely changed
over the years since, I guess, the
Kumi-daiko styles kind of started.
So, traditionally, especially when
you talk about the festival drumming
that goes on in Japan,
rhythmically, it's pretty simple
and pretty repetitive
because basically they're
accompanying a dance
or that kind of form.
And so it was [inaudible]
Gucci in Japan
that started the ensemble
format, and he was the first
to take a composition and write it
using just Taiko for itself to kind
of use those voices or
the other instruments
or having dance or
other movement to it.
And so, with that context, he
started to really look at how
to compose or create
pieces within a way
of where you're just hearing
drums with different voices
of different sites,
tones, and whatever.
And so, rhythmically, I guess,
tradition, I guess, Taiko,
when dancing or accompanying other
things is pretty much standard
for [inaudible] whatever.
But now, I guess, in contemporary
form, many groups are writing
or composers are writing and
other time signatures are just
moving around.
And so, for us in San Jose
Taiko, we've been doing
that for quite a while because we
were highly influenced by the Samba,
the Afro Cuban rhythms and
things in a polyrhythmic sense,
so we have pieces that are 7/4,
5/4, and other time signatures,
and we try to actually
move in and out of that.
So, it's not a sense at all, so
you're feeling you're just locked
into that one but just being able
to play in a different signature
so that it feels more, you know,
it feels pretty natural,
in other words.
So, but for a Taiko, traditional
Taiko player, it's very unnatural,
and so we then, again, early on
criticized because we were told
that our music was too complicated
for the Japanese Taiko audience
in general because we were just
too layered on our rhythm patterns
and taking it out of time
signature of the straight 4/4.
But whereas now, again,
you're hearing that all over,
and it's just very calming.
>> PJ Hirabayashi: Perhaps
another thing that's,
it's musical; it is your energy.
It's key or chee where in Japan,
you would see that
that's the main foundation
of like why people come together,
and I think that's what
all Taiko groups strive
to practice and also keep rooted.
So, it's not taking the Taiko drum
and making it just the instrument
to have a different sound.
It's like how do you really insert
that respect and that energy.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Thank you.
Yes. One right here then.
>> You may have answered this
question before I arrived,
and so I apologize.
When I think of Taiko drums, I
think of those great huge drums
where you have to almost lie
down in order to play them,
and when I was upset, I was
thinking, gee, I'd like to do
that to get rid of
some of my tensions.
Is that part of the
Japanese traditional Taiko,
and now you've evolved in that?
>> PJ Hirabayashi: Today's
set is very special, again.
[Laughing] [Inaudible] Taiko Group,
we couldn't get this past security,
so it had to be small drums.
So, I'm sorry, no,
no big drums today.
>> But you did it?
>> PJ Hirabayashi:
Yeah, oh yes, yes.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Do
you have any videos
on YouTube that people could find?
>> Roy Hirabayashi: Well, yes.
If you look to San Jose Taiko,
YouTube, you'll see a lot
of different videos of the
different kinds of performances.
A lot of are festival
settings, but you'll see a lot
of different drums
and concert video too.
Yes.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah.
>> I just wanted to ask a question
about the choreography movement.
You obviously, when you do the
celebration there are movements
that you're doing.
How does that relate to the rhythm?
How do you compose
or conceive those?
>> PJ Hirabayashi:
I think choreography became a
very instantaneous connection
for the expression
of San Jose Taiko.
Well, for myself, I also grew up
as a dancer, tap, ballet, you know,
but there's something, either the
cellular, the muscle memory inside,
you know, it's like that wants
to groove almost before
you become a musician.
And so that's how San Jose Taiko
was trying to integrate movement,
a lot more so than what we
saw from Japan happening.
And since then, it's like I think
people are influencing each other,
and where can you take movement?
How do you express?
Yeah
>> Roy Hirabayashi: Yeah.
>> Daniel Sheeby: Pulse
is the lighting,
the whole state there's
all sorts of -- Yes.
Sorry. I committed to,
back here next, yes.
Sorry, and thank you.
>> Thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for being here.
This is a good opportunity.
PJ, a little while earlier,
you mentioned that there were
three extinct Japantowns in LA
and San Jose and San Francisco.
Would you say that the
development of Taiko had an effect
on the preservation of those?
So, can you talk a
little bit about that?
>> PJ Hirabayashi: Yes.
Absolutely.
Well, because I think we're just
so connected to San Jose Japantown,
and our community is so
supportive of us, they go,
"You're the heartbeat
of San Jose Japantown."
And it's like, wow, I really
feel that the presence of arts
in general, you know,
and to be a part
of like all these celebrations
during the year in Japantown kind
of really elevated our prominence
and exposure, our visibility,
you know, that little
kids want to play Taiko.
So, it's like this new generation.
It's like the seeding,
right, and it's continuing.
I mean, our little kids now are now
married and have their own kids,
and we're going, oh, no kidding.
So, there's such pride and
surprise, I would say, you know,
to see that there's
kind of like, wow,
I never had that while growing
up, as the silent no-esteem kid,
you know, in kindergarten.
Now, it's like these kids
are just like flourishing
with wonderful self-esteem.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Is
this a springboard
into the Conservatory idea
because this is something special?
There are all kinds
of ways to innovate.
This is another way to innovate.
>> Roy Hirabayashi: Right.
Well, it sounds like Taiko
has been working on this idea.
Well, we've been doing
a Conservatory concept
for quite a while now.
>> PJ Hirabayashi: Program wise.
>> Roy Hirabayashi:
Program wise, right.
And so, we just feel we're trying
to put it under one category roof
of terminology in a sense, but
really it's our outreach program,
our master classes that we offer
for college to other adults.
So, it's a variety of classes,
and our training program we have
for our performing members.
We feel we have probably one of
the most vigorous training programs
for a member to join San Jose Taiko
that exists here in
the US right now.
And so, all of these things
are part of what we consider
as an important part of teaching
Taiko and also spreading it
to our performances, whether it's
our concert programming o outreach
program into the schools,
our festival programming,
and our touring that we
do as an ensemble; and so,
it's something that's
been going on for a while.
We're now on the verge of,
actually, an important piece
for us has been a physical site, and
so we're now actually moving forward
to building our own building,
along with some other partners,
so that at least we have a
permanent rehearsal space.
And so, we're just launching
a capital campaign on that,
so if anyone wants to support it.
I know you probably
understand what that means.
>> PJ Hirabayashi: And it's
happening in San Jose Japantown.
>> Roy Hirabayashi: It's in San
Jose Japantown, so we're very proud
of that too, and we're partnering
with several other
arts organizations,
but we look to have our
own permanent space.
Hopefully, within the next three
to four years that'll be
completed, so we've very excited.
>> Daniel Sheehy: And
having personally worked
at the National Endowment
for the Arts for 23 years
as though having followed the San
Jose Taiko and the Taiko in general,
I expect that this dimension
of giving to the community,
of thinking bigger than music and
performance was part of the reason
that you were awarded the
National Heritage Fellowship
by the National Endowment
for the Art as well.
So, again, one more time,
congratulations on
that, and thank you.
>> Roy Hirabayashi: Thank you.
>> Daniel Sheehy: And
there's a question here.
Yes.
>> Thank you.
I was very interested, you
know, you mentioned PJ,
your background is in dance.
Does someone who plays
another instrument have a leg
up if they decide they want
to try Taiko, say, a pianist
or a cellist, or does it matter?
>> PJ Hirabayashi: I
don't want to stereotype.
But it's really interesting
to see that people who say,
"I'm a drummer," you know,
trap drummer, I can do that;
it's a different experience.
It's like once you put the
choreography in, oh, wow,
my arm doesn't extend
that far, and I can't do
that many beats, you know.
No, these all start
from zero; in fact,
that's what we do for training.
No matter what experience you have
when you come to San Jose Taiko,
I'm sorry, you're going to have to
strip to zero because we're going
to just layer that training
within, you know, layer by layer.
>> Daniel Sheehy: So, part of our,
you have one more question here?
Yes. We want to hear a
little more music, right?
>> Yes.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah, okay.
So, let's have another question.
>> That's okay.
Just --
>> I'm just wondering, you
know, I'm from Indonesia,
and we sort of regard our
instruments as, I don't know,
holy or sacred, or we
have to respect them.
Do you teach them to respect
like you cannot step over it,
and you don't put stuff on it?
And people don't understand,
you know,
and so you always have
to teach them.
>> PJ Hirabayashi: Yes.
There's the values that are
integrated towards the practicing
of Taiko, and just because
Taiko itself is made
out of three natural elements,
wood from tree, hide from animal,
metal tacks from earth, you know,
just to really understand, wow,
this is what's gifting
us with this sound,
and each sound has its own voice.
How do you respect even that voice?
Like this drum is like
another person.
How do you respect that drum
as I can equally respect you?
So, it's like looking at
each as a living being.
>> Roy Hirabayashi: Yeah
>> I think, you know,
lots of people don't,
I think lots of people don't
understand that, you know.
>> PJ Hirabayashi: Thank
you for asking that.
>> Roy Hirabayashi: Yes.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Thank you for
that question and thank all of your
for all of your questions, and
you think you could lead us
into what's going to
happen now with the -- ?
>> PJ Hirabayashi: [Inaudible]
I think it's important.
>> Roy Hirabayashi: Okay.
>> PJ Hirabayashi: Yeah.
We're going to play this one
song actually from Japan.
It's called Hutchi Jo [phonetic],
and the reason why we want
to play this is because Hutchi Jo is
this very small island off the main
island Hornshoe, not too far from
Tokyo, and Hutchi Jo is regarded
as an island of exile where
they send political prisoners.
And yet, people were exiled
to this little island;
it still flourished as
their own community.
So, just because you are
"exiled" doesn't mean
that you can still
find beauty in life.
So, they were able to take the Hutch
Jo drum or create a Hutchi Jo drum,
or a very small drum, where it
wasn't used for art sake per se.
It was there to celebrate,
where people would just load up
and get drunk at parties,
and people just go up
and they just play on the drum.
And the reason why Roy and I really
wanted to learn this piece is
because we felt that it really kind
of paralleled the Japanese American
experience of during World War II.
The West Coast Japanese, people of
Japanese ancestry, were incarcerated
into like ten different
camps throughout the West.
And although they were there for
three years during World War II,
their communities in these
camps still were able
to find beauty and flourish.
And so, we're playing this kind
of like that sense of freedom,
sense of connection,
and finding beauty
in whatever conditions, like today.
So, we're, I'm personally
being challenged to play this
because Hutchi Jo is
usually on an up drum
like this, and it's this high.
So, if you see me whiffing at air,
it's because it's a different style.
[ Drum Performance ]
[ Audience Applause ]
>> PJ Hirabayashi: Are
there any other questions?
No.
[ Audience Laughter ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: Other than mine.
Yes? Back here, we have a question.
>> It was very beautiful.
So, I'm originally from
Los Angeles and, of course,
I know Taiko drumming, especially
at UCLA, it's very, very popular.
They used to play underground
in the parking lot
when I was there 50 years ago.
But now, I wanted to ask
about storytelling with music
and specifically with
Taiko drumming.
>> Roy Hirabayashi: Do you want?
>> PJ Hirabayashi: You go.
>> Roy Hirabayashi: Okay.
So, with that context of how Taiko
can be as storytelling, you know,
we've worked with performance
artists and theatre companies
in that way, and so and actually,
PJ has done a lot of work
with Novo Kumiamodo [phonetic],
who's based in Los Angeles,
with Great Leap [phonetic], who's a
great storyteller, dancer, singer.
And so, actually, Taiko can be used
in many different ways to accompany
that kind of action and things.
And we've been, I guess, adding
to that in different, I guess,
projects we've been doing more
recently, whether it's storytelling,
whether it's sensitive dance,
like Bhutto dance, or storytelling
within theatre, like working
with Luis Valdez and some
of its newest works that's going
on from the L. Theatre
Compasino [phonetic].
So, what we're trying to do
is really how can the music
or the voice of the Taiko be
added on to what's happening
in that context is
something we're trying to do,
and I think it's a
great opportunity.
We, personally, we'd
like to do more of that,
but it has been happening
for quite a while.
>> PJ Hirabayashi:
Just one recent project
that San Jose Taiko just
did, and their developing it,
so it'll come out again next year.
It's a collaboration of
three different groups,
and it's San Jose Taiko,
the Wesley Jazz Ensemble,
and also Epic Immersion Theatre.
So, this is just only last
weekend that it was performed,
and it was an immersive experience
where the audience were told ahead
of time, this is not a sit down
concert, that you are going to be
in the round and that actors are
going to be coming in between you,
and we also inspire you to dress
up in 1940 vintage clothing
because it was swing;
it was a swing era.
>> Roy Hirabayashi: Big Band Jazz.
>> PJ Hirabayashi: Yea.
Big Band Jazz, and
so what the story was
like Big Band Jazz
was very prominent
in these internment camps during
World War II, and it was the,
it was the activity of
dancing and making music
that people found substance
and, you know, of living
and living out their lives in camp.
And so, it was really wonderful to
see how it sparked off this energy
of people getting up and dance when
the Jazz Ensemble started to play,
you know, and then interspersed
with the dialogue to talk
about what was happening where they
had to decide and show allegiance;
do I sign up or get drafted?
You know, here I'm in camp,
but how do I show my allegiance
to America by serving the country.
So, yes, I think we're
also exploring and trying
to find those ways to
really empower the potential
of what our arts can do.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Well,
you've certainly empowered me,
and I think a number of
people in this room today.
So, PJ Hirabayashi and Roy
Hirabayashi, thank you so much.
>> Roy Hirabayashi: Thank you.
>> Daniel Sheehy: For all
you've done, [inaudible]
[ Audience Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at www.loc.gov